oh sure beans hundred-percent beans
banana peel oh wow we do baby baby Wow
hi everybody I'm Merle and today we're
going to be making something really
really weird I was online and I saw this
recipe for banana peeled pulled pork
sandwiches I'm used to people judging me
for being vegan I get it all the time
but even I like we may have gone too far
with this fun I'm gonna follow the
recipe that I found and then I'm gonna
bring in some of my co-workers and have
them try it without knowing what it is
and see if banana peels are a viable
ingredient that we should all be using
I'm using organic bananas because she
used them I did wash these first so I
would HIGHLY advise that I'm just gonna
set my bananas aside don't worry they
will not go to waste I will make a nice
little smoothie out of them later she
made this look really easy oh my god it
is really easy I'm killing this right
now you know what I'm gonna be
open-minded and I I really hope that
this tastes good I'm rooting for the
banana peel we want that stringy
consistency stringy texture just like
pulled pork this is what you want to
look like oh good okay so now it's time
to add all of our flavors feels like a
lot of seasoning for a very little bit
of food but
that's kind of telling we'll see oh yeah
look at that you can hardly even tell
what it is anymore I want to get the
texture before I cook it and then the
texture after I cook it just like a lot
of seasoning on a cold napkin you can't
taste the banana at all oh wow that rose
I cannot believe I just ate raw banana
peel okay so now I'm supposed to add
some water
that's at some barbecue sauce I'm gonna
toast some buns plop this baby on there
with some coleslaw and then I'm gonna
try it
[Music]
ready
that's pretty good I'll tell you one
thing it does not taste like bananas
the look is good the seasoning is on
point the texture isn't quite there for
me yet but like I'm gonna finish this
this is good enough that this suffice is
is lunch for me today all right I'll be
back I'm gonna whip up some more and
bring some suckers in here okay that
looks interesting it burns off it
doesn't look like everything is so
translucent looking like it's all so
thin and papery what are you looking at
looking at this little piece right here
these the texture is definitely a very
pulled porky eggplant and then also this
I initially thought the carrot it is a
carrot it's both long oh wow that's
another way to do it I'll give you a
cover minute
they're gonna thought it would be so
sorry
yeah go for another bite Oh sour sour
better than jackfruit for sure there's a
good little Blake to make contact with
me not me but it's so good I wish they
were honestly more of the feeling or
whatever the whole pork I've used a
different vegan substitute ingredient
that one may not normally use paper bugs
right
cabbage tofu soy no that's very broad
but no it could be anything
no it's not a mushroom it's actually a
fruit beans no something you normally
throw away for my fruit so it's like an
end
it has ends beans this is the beam right
here isn't it oh sure beans hundred
percent beans banana peel like that -
competing compost I'm sorry no way again
man you know banana fields can be used
for a lot of things a little freaked out
but I'm like I would I would eat it
again I actually liked it a lot Wow it's
pretty it's pretty crazy you know cuz my
Safari
I put work better than this but mm-hmm I
will eat this oh this is the substitute
I'm not vegan
and why would I replace put pork with a
banana
well it's cheap Oh anime beheld and
cutting down on waste that's it figure
like you're not gonna do that